l'équipe 2 face yvelines réunis pour
célébrer les 20 ans du club
d'entreprises avec ses actions de job
academy de graines d'entreprises ou de
manteaux ring la fondation accompagne
depuis 1999 les acteurs économiques dans
leur engagement sociétal pour un avenir
sans exclusion une philosophie qui n'a
pas changé depuis deux décennies
on cherche à faire que les gens qui sont
dans le trou c'est à dire les gens qui
ont des difficultés à trouver un emploi
retrouve l'énergie nécessaire pour
retrouver eux-mêmes un emploi et on
essaye de faire que les jeunes qui sont
dans les quartiers défavorisés
réussissent à avoir un projet
professionnel en vantant le bilan est
positif une centaine de partenaires
impliqués
dix mille personnes ont été accompagnées
par la structure parmi elles sentent ya
en décembre 2017 nous l'avions suivi
lors d'une opération de manteaux ring au
collège gustave courbet de trappe alors
élève en 3e elle avait pu découvrir
l'univers de l'entreprise thalès et
consolider son projet d'orientation
j'ai pu surtout m'améliorer à l'oreille
parce que c'est pas vraiment quelque
chose ou à je suis à l'aise et comme je
fais du journalisme je pense que c'est
ra prend fin les tuteurs continue à
suivre ses élèves tout au long de
l'année et on espère bien pouvoir
poursuivre ce partenariat avec le
collège et le club fasse pour voir
l'avenir un petit peu plus loin et
essayer de continuer cette action qui
est bénéfique pour tout le monde
objectif de faciliter pour les
prochaines années continuer à développer
ses actions sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi dans le
nord de notre département